Okay, Michael so we talked a little bit about the curse of dimensionality,
but I think it's worthwhile to talk about some other stuff that comes
up. We've been sort of skirting around this and you know bring it
up in various ways throughout our discussion so far. But I think it's worthwhile
kind of writing them all down on a slide and trying to think
through them for a little bit. So ,uh, the other stuff that comes
up in [UNKNOWN] mainly comes up in these sort of assumptions we make
about parameters to the algorithm. So the one we talked about ,uh, probably the
most is our distance measure, you know our
distance between some X and some query point Q
and we've explored a couple. We looked at
Eucudean and we looked at Manhattan. And we even
looked at weighted versions of those. And this
really matters, I've said this before but I really
think it bears repeating that your choice of
distance function Really matters. If you pick the wrong
kind of distance function, you're just going to get very poor behavior.
>> So I, so I have a question about these these distance functions.
So you mentioned Euclidean and Manhattan,
are there other distance functions that the
students should know? Like, things that they, that might come up, or things
that they should think of first if they have a particular kind of data?
>> yeah, there's a, there's a ton of them. I think Well, first off,
it, it's probably worth pointing out that
this, this notion of weighted distance is one
way to deal with the curse of dimensionality. You can weight
different dimensions differently. And that would be one, and you might
come up with sort of automatic ways of doing that. That,
that's sort of worth mentioning. But you will notice that both Euclidean
and Manhattan distance at least as we have talked about them,
are really useful for things like regression. Their kind of assuming
that you have numbers in that subtraction kind of makes sense.
But there are other functions, distance functions that you might do if
you are dealing with cases like, I don't know Discrete
data, right? Where instead of it all being numbers, it's colors,
or something like that. Alright so, your distance might be mismatches.
For example, or it might be a mixture of those. In
fact, one of the nice things about KNN, is that
we've been talking about it with points, because it's sort of
easy to think about it that way. But this distance function
is just a black box. You can take Arbitrary things and
try to decide how similar they are based on whatever you
know about the domain and that could be very useful. So
,you could talk about images right, where you take pictures of
people and you know rather than doing something like a pixel
by pixel comparison, you try to line up their eyes. And
look at their mouths, and try to see if they're the
same shape you know things like that, that might be more
complicated and and perhaps even arbitrarily
computational to determine notions of similarity
so really this idea of distance in similarity tells
you a lot about your domain and what you
believe about it. ,another thing that's worth what what's
pushing on a little bit is how you pick k.
Well there's no good was to pick k you
just You just have to know something about it, but
I want to think about a particular case. Well,
what if we end up in a world where K=N.
>> Well, that would be silly.
>> Why would it be silly?
>> Well, so if K=N, then what you're doing is you're taking, so in the case
of regression for example, you're taking all
of the data points and averaging the.
Y values together. Basically ignoring the query.
So, you end up with a constant function.
>> But that's only if you do a
simple average. What if you do a weighted average?
>> A weighted average. So the near, the points that are
the query are going to get more weight in the average, so
that acually will be diffrent. Even though k equals n, it
will be different depending on where you actually put your query down.
>> Exactly. That's exactly right so, for example, if I have
a little bunch of points like this say. Where you notice it
kind of looks like I have two different lines here and
I can pick a query point way over here, all of these
points are going to influence me as oppose to these points and
so I'm going to end up. Estimating with something that looks more
like this because these points over here won't have much to
say. But if I have a query point that's way over here
somewhere these points are going to matter and I'm going to end up
looking something looks a little bit more like this than like
that. Now I'm drawing these as lines. They won't exactly look
like lines because these points will have some influence. They'll be more
curvy than that. But the point is that near, near
the place we want to do the query it will
look To be more strongly influenced by these points over
here or these points over here depending on where you are.
>> Well that gives me an idea.
>> Oh, what kind of idea does it give you?
>> Well, what about instead of just taking
a weighted average, what about using the distance matrix
to pick up some of the points? And
then do a different regression on that substantive point.
>> Right, I like that.
So we can replace this whole notion of
average with a more kind of, regression-y thing.
>> So it actually, instead of using the same value for
the whole patch. Actually, it still continues to use the input values.
>> Yeah. So, in fact, average is just
a special case of a kind of regression, right?
>> Mm hm, mm hm.
>> Right? So this actually has a name,
believe it or not. It's actually called locally
weighted regression. Yeah, so this actually works pretty
well and in place of sort of averaging
function, you can do just about anything you want to.
You could throw in a decision tree, you could throw in
a neural network, you could throw in lines do linear
regression. You can do, almost anything that you can imagine doing.
>> Neat,
>> Yeah. Add that works out very well. And again, it
gives you a little bit of power. So here's something I don't
think is very obvious until it's pointed out to you. Which is
this notion of replacing the average with a more general regression or
even classification function. It actually allows
you to do something more powerful
than it seems. So let's imagine that we were going to do locally
weighted regression and we were going to do, in fact, linear regression. So,
what would locally- weighted linear regression look like? Well, if we go
back to this example over here on the left basically, you take
all the points that are nearby and you try to fit a
line to it. And, so you would end up with stuff that
looked, pretty much, like this. While you're over here, you would get
the line like this, but while you were over here you'd
get a line like this. Then, somewhere in the middle you
would get lines that started to look like this and And
you would end up with something that kind of ended up looking
a lot like a curve. So that's kind of cool because
you notice that we start with a hypothesis state of lines
and this locally weighted linear regression. But then we end up
actually being able to represent a hypothesis space that is strictly bigger.
than the set of lines. Hm. So we can
use a very simple kind of hypothesis space but by
using this locally weighted regression we end up with
a more complicated space that is complicated, that's made more
complicated depending upon the complications that are represented by
your data points. So this results, this sort of reveals
another bit of power with kNN. Which is, it
allows you to take local information and build functions or
build concepts around the local things that are similar to
you. And that allows you to make arbitrarily complicated functions.
>> Neat.
>> At least in principle. Okay, cool. Alright so you got all that?
>> I, think so yeah.
>> Okay, cool. So then, I think we should wrap up.
>> Nice.